lisa is going to be with us in Nebraska
hi Lisa welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi Dave I'm so happy to talk to you you
too thank you my husband and I could use
your advice on whether to sell our home
or not he had to retire early due to
medical reasons and he is 60 I'm 57 and
we weren't ready to financially retire
and so now we are kind of trying to
decide I've got about three to four
years left before I can retire and we
are wondering do we go ahead and sell
our home now and get out of a house
payment and put those proceeds from our
sales to our retirement and then we
won't have a house payment or do we at
home should be paid off probably at
about the same time in four years do we
wait and then just take the recedes and
put it into our retirement at that time
so where are you going to live well we
thought we would downsize and get a
smaller home and then just pay for it
outright oh okay
and put the balance into your retirement
plan right yes yeah well either one's
fun would you like to do that well we
just didn't know if I nationally what
would make more sense if we should do it
now or wait down the road mathematically
mathematically if you do it now you
don't have a house payment so you can
save more okay that's kind of what we
wondered we're really we were just torn
we kind of like our house but yet on the
other hand it's probably 100 Michelle
thanks anyway
probably about 475 and what would you
buy and we and maybe around hopefully
around a 300 top okay and you would have
no house payment at that point right but
you have a house payment now come on
okay and he
you are in what I am in the school
system so I would receive a pension but
I've probably got well it depends if I
if I can hold off for four years to
reach full benefits or if I go in four
years 57 I know I'm I'm to be honest I'm
getting a little burned out okay all
right and so how much money do you all
have in your nest egg we have in his
nest egg for sixty-five 465,000 and you
don't have one at all except your
pension would be coming right if I
retire in two years two and a half years
my pension would be about eighteen
hundred and if you wait for it be how
much about twenty three hundred
twenty-three twenty-four $6,000 your
difference not huge okay okay what's the
nature of his medical disability he has
and he develops seizures and he is
working for a farmer but he was working
for an electric company and so those two
just don't really go together so he had
to retire yeah she's working for a
farmer mm-hmm yeah just to supplement
our income not she okay all right yeah I
mean I here's the thing I turned 60 this
year so there's not anything that says
he can't start a brand new career true
mm-hmm I mean unless the seizures keep
him from doing not necessarily at a
nine-to-five job but he could start a
business where he controls what he does
right what did he do with the electric
company he worked on the substations
okay yeah with the high voltage you
don't need to have a high voltage
situation with the seizure that would
probably not be a plan okay I get it and
what could you do to your situation to
make it more fun to finish the four
I know I have thought about I really and
I actually have an hour and ten minutes
amigos both directions my school I think
I know can you get closer that would
help yes I think so too yeah I think a
change of scenery would be good for you
we give you the energy to finish out and
I think he needs to not think of this
early retirement as mandatory mm-hmm I
think it's you instead of an early
retirement maybe it's a change of
direction yeah I think so I think he's
making it I think he's making a lot less
right now then he's probably worth
mm-hmm he could make a lot more if he
thought this through a little bit more
so I want to incur I want to encourage
him today to start a brand new business
and have this next 20 years be amazing
while he but for between 60 and 80 go
make a million dollars yeah you know or
work for a farmer I mean let's go do
something great because sometimes it's
just a mentality of I can't do my job
anymore because of medical and so I have
to sit down oh well instead sitting down
I'll pick vegetables but you know maybe
there's something else to do maybe
there's an encore career where the
curtain goes up curtain goes down we
take a bow and go do it again so I don't
know I I just encourage you in that
regard because sometimes these some of
the stuff is more of a mentality than it
is anything else you're okay financially
you're not gonna be be eating Alpo I
mean you're gonna be alright if you want
to accentuate this and make your savings
grow faster because you don't have a
house payment then move down now and pay
cash for your move down that's not a bad
plan but I think these two income parts
of the equation that we're discussing
his and yours might be a more important
part of the overall discussion that's
why I went there so we talked about it a
lot around here Wednesday of gonna
retire he's not they're gonna take me
out of here feet first or babbling one
of the two so if I stop making sense on
the air
they have the right to pull me off the
air because there are people in
broadcasting stay on the air beyond
their ability to make sense and they
shouldn't do
that but yeah and I'm not gonna name any
names but you know who I'm talking about
so anyway yeah I'm as long as I could
come around here and spread hate and
dissension I'm gonna do it so that's my
plan I cuz I love what I do I don't need
money I haven't needed money for a long
time but I like helping you guys and I
like hearing your stories of success and
winning and so I'll continue to speak
I'll continue to do the show what I'm
not gonna do is continue to run the
company because it's not good for the
company and not good for my kids the
next generation coming on and so you
know I'm 60 coming this year so sometime
in the next decade you'll see me step
out of that role as some of them are
ready to move into that role and we
finish up the leadership transitions
around here but I'll become just another
MC personality except not as good as the
other ones so there you go they're
already better than me but they're just
not getting paid as well so there you go
I'm not leaving people not leaving until
you make me when nobody's listening I'll
still come down here because I own the
microphone